means of thanks for receiving us here at
the yield Divinity School adil
university new haven your professor here
for faith and culture to introduce you
to the audience of the nexus institute
where do you come from and why have you
chosen to become a few lodging i was
born in what was then you Islamiyah and
i was born born to a man who was a
minister and most of our life we were
revolved around faith and life of a
small community and i promptly rebelled
when I was about 13 years of age and
then discovered faith in the 16 when I
was 16 and from then on couldn't quite
help myself but think through the basic
issues of faith which are the basic
issues of human existence and by the way
at that time in Yugoslavia being a
theologian was really cool it was
something that had to do with not just
my existence but also that had to do
with a position to the reigning regime
and we thought we were doing something
countercultural and something on which
the future another only of our lives but
on of our country and of the world
depends okay and now we live in a time
in which a vast majority of people and
will realize that to save the world yes
we have science Chris technology
politics can play a role and
international law will play a role but
what is it that fee ology has to offer
to the world well theology is about in
many ways a reflection on the nature of
human existence nature of human the
problem of human
human existence and theology can attend
to questions of global issues of justice
but but theology also does is it zeroes
in on the deep recesses of human heart
and human desire and tries to examine
who we as human beings are as connected
to what is it that we identify with
project ourselves into how the dynamics
of our desire and desire functions and I
think that we can't save the world
unless we save the desire of each of
human human beings and theology has very
much something to say about this but
then what's the difference between a
philosophy psychology and social
sciences and feel you because you are a
theology of this Christian theology t.t
mai tais as the world and human beings
not just in themselves or it dymatize
'as them as themselves only as they are
related to something that's beyond the
bond rebounder of this world that's
beyond beyond the boundary of their
existence in other words if demonizes
human beings as fundamentally are
related to transcendence so that the
world is not just cosmos the world is
creation the world is a gift and
therefore always more than what appears
to our senses in the world there's
always moral it's always the case that
more than the world is the case to quote
slaughter dicks comment about the
secular seminary this is what theology
brings to our attention in our own lives
we are always more than just ourselves
we live eccentrics existence and this
reference of the entire world and human
beings to transcendence is fundamental
to us and I think if we do not think of
human beings in
those terms we cannot understand who
human beings are we cannot understand
what the problem of human existence is
and we cannot certainly imagine how
salvation might might look like